can i mention
one of my favorite door victories and
i'm curious about the disposition of a
particular item the 2006 emmy awards
conan challenged all the writers conan
jose emmy's in 2002 and then he got
asked to host him again in 2006. okay
and so i guess having one under this
belt he was really attacked writing the
show with gusto and he's like he's like
you know what
i'm gonna give just to motivate all the
writers i'm going to give a gold coin to
the writer who comes up with the best
bit
for the emmy awards
and um
[Music]
and we're like
what is this a game show
yeah okay i'm going to tell you a little
bit about that
we were already the writing process for
conan hosting the emmys was underway
right and the difficulty that was
emerging was we couldn't find a
live thing for him to do in the show in
the run of the show like we had a lot of
pre-taped little bits
of the yin yang but no big live but
nothing live
and so
you know the word had gone out come on
guys live stuff all right so we had one
meeting nothing we had another meeting
nothing then we were called into conan's
presence and ahab like
if for moby dick fans out there right
ahab like he said i have now have a gold
a 50 gold cougar coin which he showed us
yeah us mint gold coin he'd gotten
and it was still in its wrapper and
everything so it's like a fifth you know
50 gold coin and he's like i will give
it
to the person that comes up with a live
thing
in the
for me to do so that's how it started it
didn't it wasn't just for the best thing
in the show okay a live
thing yeah okay it was an intentional
ahab yeah it was an intentional thing
about
he made a big dramatic show
he was being funny about it it was
really at the same time yeah but it was
also a real challenge yeah yeah like his
baseball manager it was real and funny
at the same time yes
the way he talked to those baseball
players was pretty much the way he was
talking to us
that's not that wasn't unreal you're
sending me out there with nothing yeah i
pay you for top chop and you give me
chump rump
those are things that were said to us
indefinitely in in earnest repeatedly so
yeah so
so he says there's gonna be a gold coin
in it for you if you can come up with a
live stream
then
i pitched the idea of someone likeable
or even lovable
and i said likable level we everyone had
pitched a thing to do with will ferrell
like that had already happened a lot
because it was just the thing at the
time well fair was this we'll throw it
as that right right because he was very
useful and they're always game so yeah
his name is coming up so i pitched we
have a person not will ferrell
[Laughter]
but who's very well liked but not will
ferrell
who has to sit in a booth that only has
two hours of air in it and then that
will be the basis of our keep it short
speech for the for the for the winners
like keep it short or that person runs
out of air and dies
oh that's so funny because i had said
not well farrell i didn't have the right
answer for their person would be
but the room took it from there and
everyone started throwing out names and
i'm pretty sure dan cronin said bob
newhart
and the idea of bob newhart with two
hours of air
and keep it short of bob newhart dies
completely and instantly
seemed like the right way to go yeah
sweeney left the meeting went you know
20 feet over down the hall to talk to
conan about it and came back within a
few minutes and said that's where we're
going so
it was a yes right away and then conan
like
i'm pretty sure he drafted a letter on
bonded paper yeah i'm like fedexed it to
type it yeah the whole like it was
really very very official and he like
he put the request in like bonded letter
form and sent it to bob newhart
and uh and yeah you wrote a personal
letter it was really really neat and
then new heart said yes that's great and
so that's how that came to be and then i
believe sweeney and gordon just dealt
with it at the i mean i wasn't there for
the production week but did you get the
gold coin i did yeah
i was given the golden coin did you have
it appraised
well it's high right you could look up
the value of the coin every day uh
because
the value of an ounce of gold was
turned into an nft and we lived you know
our office was like two streets away
from 47th street you could go
turn the coin in for cash at any time
yeah and i kept it for several several
years because that was a great show the
2006 emmys yeah
is rock solid and that really was i just
watched someone put together all the bob
newhart bits
because then cody introduced a bit and
bob newhart's rolled off and looking
panic it's like
it's funny because bob's learning about
the bit while conan's describing it and
he has that great bob newhart
face of like
oh [ __ ] wait what
and then
like you know an hour later does a bit
where he goes
ugh i'm sorry that was a waste of
everyone's time and then it just card
cuts to bob newhart backstage in the
booth